settlement on the 28th and 29th of
september there was another online
meeting of the country group on conflict
settlement in eastern ukraine and its
subgroups it resulted in an unpleasant
but not surprising outcome namely lack
of any specific arrangements between the
parties to the conflict kiev donetsk and
luhansk ukrainian negotiators once again
showed their unwillingness to implement
their commitments under the minsk
agreements kiev's course at undermining
the package of measures is reflected in
law making activities previously we've
already talked about a draft law on
principles of state policy of the
transitional period that was submitted
to the virgo nevada in august this year
and that is in direct contradiction with
the minsk agreements it was not
discussed with donetsk luhansk and it
has no place for special status
of the region a major rights and amnesty
for its citizens interestingly this new
report of the un high commissioner for
human rights that was published on the
23rd of september 2021 recognizes that
this draft law does not comply with
international standards and does not
ensure the implementation of approach
aimed at victims protection
neglect by kiev to the fate of donors
citizens is confirmed by the situation
at the line of conflict
um the
report of the osce smm
confirmed a new military preparations of
the ukraine armed forces engineering
works carried out by armed forces are
characterized as offensive according to
the measures to strengthen the ceasefire
that were adopted in july 2020. recently
chief of the ukrainian armed forces
valerie solution zelazny uh claimed that
ukrainian military can open fire
retaliatory fire uh without the
agreement from its leadership it also
confirmed that ukrainian sniper groups
came to the line of cont or contact and
it all contradicts the provisions of the
merchant document
so you get an impression that the
ukrainian
leadership abandoned donbass and its
citizens that's exactly the same
situation faced by ukrainians abroad
ukrainian consular facilities
uh deny consular services to their
citizens and
they send these citizens hailing from
the east of the country to the
consulates of russia such cases are an
outrage for the consular practice and
naturally russian diplomats try to do
their best
to help these citizens
hostile relations
and attitude of the kiev regime to its
own citizens is witnessed throughout the
territory of ukraine there is an ongoing
discrimination of the russian-speaking
population
experts of the united nations note that
the ukrainian constitution provides for
guarantees for the free
development and the use and protection
of russian and other languages of
national minorities yet the country
virtually bans the use of the russian
language
and the citizens of ukraine
face bullying by now nazis and their
nationalists
over the memory of their ancestors
and all these and other grievances have
been repeatedly voiced by us however
kiev turns a blind eye both to our
recommendations and recommendations of
international entities we urge western
mentors of ukraine primarily the u.s and
the eu to
focus
on
this
degrading attention by the kiev regime
of its own population
and today on the 30th of september
the osce observer mission
is ending its mandate
in the checkpoints of gucovo and doniazk
in the near future all of the osce staff
will leave the russian territory the
deployment of this field presence in
summer 2014 was a gesture of our
goodwill we made this step as a
confidence building measure expecting
that would encourage the ukrainian
authorities to opt for the peaceful
settlement in donbass unfortunately over
the past seven years the step was not
reciprocated and was not duly understood
by the cave authorities and their
western partners moreover the very
presence of the osce observers was used
by a number of states
as a pretext to fuel confrontation so in
this context it was not reasonable to
extend
the group's mandate we don't have any
grievances whatsoever to the activities
of the group it was coordinating
its efforts and it has not recorded any
movement of troops or military equipment
throughout the border
let me also mention that this mission
was deployed before the signing of the
minsk agreements and it is not mentioned
in either minsk one or minsk two or
further documents of the contact group
we hope that now the ukrainian
authorities and their western partners
will take a more responsible approach
and will stop
shifting the blame for us on us for
stalling the peaceful settlement
in ukraine
we are concerned about fuelling tensions
between tajik and afghanistan
there are reports of armed forces being
pulled to the
common border
and according to the taliban movement
border afghan province of tahar hosts
dozens of thousands of fighters of
special units we urge dusan ben kabul to
seek mutually acceptable solutions there
are some challenges in social and
economic situation in afghanistan there
is a decrease in cash turnover and the
banking sector is paralyzed the
overwhelming majority of civil servants
including taliban military do not
receive any payment
the dire situation and national economy
leads to a spike in prices and drop in
production in these conditions we took
note of the u.s treasury decision
that allows state entities international
entities and ngos to provide
humanitarian assessment assistance to
afghanistan we believe it is a positive
step
we note another statement by the
official representative of the taliban
movement zebular moja hit on the
intention to stop drug smuggling from
afghanistan we look forward to active
efforts of the color bull authorities
aimed at curbing the afghan drug drug
threat
we took note of the statement
by
uh state
secretary blinken that
accused russia of uh
obstructing the
meeting
of the osc
we believe that this statement is
another attempt to distort the true
state of affairs from the beginning of
this year when consultation started on
the topic and modalities of the warsaw
meeting the russian side clearly
outlined its priorities namely russia
insisted that the agenda of
that the agenda should include events on
combating glorification of nazism and
neo-nazism
moreover we spoke in favor of organizing
the warsaw meeting in line with the
established practice and the necessary
condition for this is ensuring equal and
non-discriminatory access for all of its
participants including ngos
and the swedish chairman in office and
western partners refused to take into
account russian proposals which is
perplexing namely i'm referring to
neglecting the problem of
neonatal sentiments gaining the upper
hand
this
i believe
will contribute to blocking control over
the grading human rights situation
and we believe that this step is
ill-fated
and it also undermines the spirit of
partnership and cooperation within the
osce
we
welcome
a decision by the lithuanian
court
that
recognized the illegitimacy of actions
by the radio and tv commission
to suspend the broadcasting of the rtr
planet channel
let me remind you that in february 2018
it banned
its broadcasting on the territory of the
country and the court also canceled the
decision of this commission of april
2018 that find the lithuanian tv channel
provider um in it company for
broadcasting another uh option version
of the channel with rasia rtr
so the principle of impartiality within
the commission was distorted
its decisions could be biased and could
promote the interests of certain persons
let me remind you that russia has been
trying to draw the attention to this
matter in international platforms and in
2018 we called to take note of
violations in decision making process
and we urged to protect the rights of a
tangible part of the population of
lithuania that wanted to get information
from russian-speaking sources
instead of it the eu
followed the will of lithuania on the
4th of may 2018 the european commission
issued a decree recognizing the ban on
broadcasting this channel
we have already
expressed our position regarding the
cynicism and double standards
of the decision made by the european
commission we also want to know whether
other decisions by this commission will
be reviewed
that also banned the broadcasting of our
teach tv channel
or the lithuanian leadership will
continue to insist on this destructive
policy of our
uprooting russian-speaking media
presence with tasted agreement of senior
european
brothers
as for
the moldovan issue we took note of a
batch of u.s military equipment that was
shipped on the 26th of september
according to the media report it has to
do with small arms
light weapons armored vehicles
by the end of the year several u.s
batches were also announced we assume
that such steps that fit in the overall
course of washington and brussels at
dragging moldova to the euro-atlantic
entities will hardly
facilitate
trust between the hosts of nista and it
will make it even more complicated to
have this transnistrian settlement
process
we also take note of reports on oslo's
plan
regarding the border control on
swabad
and the
norwegian authorities justify their
decision by allegedly to ensure security
on the archipelago
as you know article 3 of 1920 swarber
treaty provides for the same free access
to the citizens of all
parties or to the treaty
for any purpose and task to waters fuels
and ports of the archipelago bearing
this in mind we believe that this is an
infringement on the 1920 treaty
currently border and other types of
control are not carried out for sea and
air passengers coming to and from the
archipelago that do not head to the
continental norway part of norway should
the innovation side introduce this
border control as well but
these new developments may worsen the
access to archipelago triggering
unwanted repercussions for the
treaty-based activities
for individuals and legal entities we
assume that norwegian authorities will
abstain from such actions that violate
1920 swarberg treaty
from our part we have
repeatedly urged to
build up our military our bilateral
interaction on the matter of combating
terrorism
now the ball is in the court of the
norwegian partners
now let's get down to um
the nikiferoff case on the 10th of may
alba court sentenced russian citizen
alexey negrov
arrested in denmark for alleged
cooperation with russian security
services and it centers it to three
years in prison our compatriot does not
recognize his guilt
and made an appeal
it is not worthy that the court ignored
arguments provided by the russian
citizen that the accusation hold no
water
the verdict
mentions
no nothing whatsoever
that his scientific activities had
damaged in some way uh the danish side
uh we believe that uh
the court just
formalized the decision that has already
been made we expect objective and
unpoliticized
consideration of his case and we believe
that um
the russian compatriot was subjected to
lawlessness
and we hope that he will be released
ensuring just consideration of niger of
case uh is within the purview of russian
mfa
a russian embassy to denmark continues
to provide
consular assistance to uh this citizen
and we keep in touch with his legal
advisor
once again
nasi military criminal who moved to
canada avoided punishment for a military
crime just like in the case
of
handman of catin
vladimir katrik who died in 2015
german oberland who had served in center
commander cc 10a
and who had been involved in
the massacre of 214 soviet children in
the orphanage in his in 1942 as well as
civilians of the krasnodar region and
the eurostov area died without getting
one's fear the inherent canadian justice
that has been
seeking only the deportation of him
for more than two decades
uh
proved to be incapable
of
making
the proper decision and let it remain on
the conscience of the official ettava
that
manifested unacceptable admissiveness
towards nasa in their accomplices
since the 27th of
september till the 5th of october 1941
moscow hosted a conference of
representatives of the soviet union the
united states and great britain to
discuss the issue of supplying each
other all they needed to fight against
the germany
germany of hitler the delegation of
great britain was headed by minister of
supply william
bilbert burke uh the united states were
represented by special adviser of the
president william over del german and uh
the soviet site was represented by
stalin molotov in the protocol signed
following the results of the conference
so called the first moscow protocol
it was mentioned that western allies
undertook to deliver monthly to the
soviet union the great amount of weapons
military equipment supplies and food
at the conference it was also
decided to
reinform
uh
reformat
the
agreement into
a act as of the 12th of july 1921 into a
treaty valid not only during the war but
also after the first batch
uh upon the moscow protocol arrived to
the united uh to the soviet union at the
end of october back then franklin
roosevelt announced
on the decision of the american
government to apply the
land lease law to the soviet union
the decisions of the moscow conference
became the first agreement on the real
cooperation an
important step towards the establishment
of an anti-hitler coalition and at the
closing
meeting molotov highlighted that the
uniting
powers of all
the uh
world's greatest countries were
determined
were the most important factors to
determine the successful outcome
um on the 26th
of september in london there was an
exchange of letters between soviet
ambassador ivan maske and general de
gaulle on the recognition
of him as the
leader of all true french who refused to
surrender to the enemy and who
stood on the path of countering fascism
the soviet union
expresses readiness to provide
assistance to all the french patriots
the
the heroism of the soviet uh militants
who took part in the french resistance
movements became a very a bright example
of the french
soviet brotherhood at arms in his letter
to generation the goal ambassador maisky
expressed his determination
uh to
assure the restoration of the greatness
and the independence of france once the
joint victory is achieved so we can see
that the support to france was
unconditional
and absolute though the french territory
was over the control of the
collaboration regime official the soviet
union firm believed into the joint
future victory
and wanted france to preserve its status
of the great power nowadays when france
and the soviet union are facing common
threads it's important to keep the
memories of the
uh brotherhood at arms and to
cherish the memory of alliance and
fraternity
[Music]
on the 25th of september this year
slovakia
the village of storytech in the
framework of events dedicated to the
77th anniversary of the liberation of
the country
of the euro term by the red army
uh
hosted the inauguration of a moment
dedicated to a commander of the great
patriotic war twice here of the soviet
union marshall malinowski's
the monument was erected upon the
project of a well-known sculpture
slobomir ghibi upon the initiative and
at the expense of the citizens of
slovakia the ceremony
united representatives of the committee
on the international affairs of the
group of friendship with russia's
national council of the republic
uh mary and kerry representatives of
local authorities veterans at the
public organization the ambassador of
russia to slovakia brazikov also took
part in it these speeches the solemn
ceremony highlighted the inadmissibility
to distort history and the daughter of
um
marshall malinowski addressed the
participants of the event
she
thanked
everyone for perpetrating the memory of
your father
on the grounds of slovakia it's not
worthy that this country cherishes the
memory of the liberators of the country
we're grateful for that to slovakia and
to its people
the russian federation continues to
provide the republic of oppressor
multi-faceted assistance in fighting
against the dissemination of the new
chronovirus infects
infection
um a great contribution is made by
multifaceted mobile hospital of the
russian minister of defense more than
that from the 19th of august till the
24th of september the complex and
disinfection events in the republic was
conducted by the unions of radiation
chemical and biological protection of
the army course of the black sea fleet
we need to highlight that it is the
second visit of the mobile hospital to
abhasia the
medical uh the military magic
doctors worked for the first time in the
republics in the republic from the uh
from october 2020 till march 2021 russia
regularly provides apartheid with test
system with vaccines from coronavirus
different medical equipment russian
specialists
and health professionals provide their
colleagues in abraham with all the
practical methodological and
consultative assistance we intend to
continue this close cooperation with the
republicans the area of health care
uh the mass media of iceland published
information
on
alleged attacks
against the company of
gay daikin
and
we witnessed that in west there is an
order to come up with accusations
against russia so it is iceland's turned
we would like to say that the
accusations are groundless we would like
to remind that
um in russia there is a national
coordination center on computer
incidents that is entitled to cooperate
with the relevant bodies of foreign
countries and their relevant agencies in
order to counter malicious activities in
the cyberspace according to our data
there were no
requests
to this center and russia has been
consistently speaking a favor and
consolidating international cooperation
in the area of country and cybercrime
it's upon our initiative that the u.n
commission on developing a comprehensive
convention on
on fighting against the use of icts and
criminal purposes was established in
july 2021 russia
introduced and submitted a draft of such
a convention to the special committee
moreover we are preoccupied
with the
piece of information according to which
emits
the growing uh hearing drug addiction
and under the circumstances of the
pandemic european countries use more and
more often so-called programs of the
reduced home for example
paris allowed opening
so-called so-called injection rooms
where truck addicted can use hard trucks
in so-called secure conditions according
to three anti-drug conventions of the
united nations uh the choice of matters
to cure drug addiction is a prerogative
of which countries nevertheless these
programs of home reduction do not
pursue the purpose to
cure
the citizens completely and they
lead to recognizing drug addiction as a
social norm we hope to continue
cooperating with france to consolidate
the existing regime of truck control and
to implement the u.n political documents
in this area would like to invite our
partners to another meeting of the
international initiative paris park that
is scheduled to take place from the 15th
till the 16th of december in moscow to
discuss the trans-border aspects of
fighting against opiate tract problem
we'd also like to
draw attention to the innovative
forms of the seo work
that
are aimed at using all the potential of
its member states was very
important to solve the national
development tasks on the 29th of
september chulabinsk uh
hosted the second meeting of the forum
of the seo member states
uh it
gathered representatives of regional
administrations and economic agencies
and business circles of russia india
kazakhstan china kyrgyzstan pakistan
pakistan
the focus was made on the issues of
developing trade economic investment
cooperation between the regions of the
seo countries including the context of
implementing the program of
interregional cooperation of the seo
member states adopted
in june 2019 in bishkek the forum of
their heads of regents
the
founding
meeting of which took place in october
gives
a lot of good opportunities to involve
observers and seo partners
into the dialect
in order to implement efficiently the
potential of this mechanism the
chulabinsk area proposed
to
establish russian national part of the
forum that's
included the areas of fasterhan
kurgan um samara
and on the emergence of the event uh
roadmap was signed
and in conclusion
on the 27th of september the institute
aimed named after matthias ramirez
hosted the immigration ceremony of
russian language classes for the
employees of the magical diplomatic
agency the development of russian
medical cooperation including the
framework of the meredith mutual
understanding in academic and diplomatic
circles
uh in 2020s in 2017 uh between the
diplomatic academy of the russian
foreign ministry and the foreign
ministry of mexico has been brought into
a new level which is showed by the
growing interests of mexican diplomats
to learn in russian the course
attendance include 45
employees of the
foreign ministry of
mexico
including senior junior employees it is
expected that
diplomats learning
russian will be enlisted
into the reserve of appointments for
for work abroad we'd like to express our
um
gratefulness to the leadership of the uh
foreign minister of mexico and to the
institution for their support in the
promotion of russian language in mexico
we will provide all the necessary
insistence in involving new
teachers of the russian language and
then choosing guidebooks we
are sure that the implementation of this
project will enable the participants to
the classes to get acquainted better
with the history and the culture of our
country now let's uh proceed with the
question
the international life
are you there
good afternoon do you hear me yes i can
hear you
i've got one question
the president of the czech republic
signed a decree
that will
may crush and check companies withdrawal
from the
construction of the atomic
station
dukkhavan what is your reaction that is
true the president of the czech republic
signed uh
the
law
uh upon the uh opposition the liberal
position of the country this law
included provisions discriminated
potential participants to the project
and
the law stipulated that
only
technologies of countries
taking part in the wto agreement on
governmental purchases
will take part in the construction of
new blocks and russia and china do not
take part in this agreement the
uh law will enter into force on the
first of january 2021 we regret that
despite the economic logic and
to the detriment of the interest of
the
interpretation
in the state uh prague
used such a politicized and biased
approach it is not a secret that russia
has been a very good and long-standing
partner of the czech republic in this
area and we have had a very fruitful
cooperation with it
we draw attention to the fact that
previously the heart of the czech
republic hadn't supported the adoption
of such a law
noting that it will make the project
be more expensive
the public television of armenia yes
please the public television of romania
i can
see you on the screen but i don't see
you here do you hear me now yes
maria garam
if you allow me i have several questions
today in the framework of the young
general assembly
the first
meeting of foreign minister framini
azerbaijan took place as a core
chair how does russia assess uh this
situation and can we state that under
the auspices of it the uh process on the
gornikara ba has been renewed and the
second question on the 28th of september
russian foreign minister
uh lavrov said in new york that
co-chairs agreed on the issues of
renewing original visits
and when is the original visit of
co-chairs is scheduled and what agenda
will there be we'd like to confirm once
again that
uh foreign minister lavrov gave a
positive assessment of the efforts of
the co-chairs of the osce means group
very important result
is the
meeting that took place in new york and
the fact that both countries uh
participating in the conflicts
agreed to
continue searching for means to solve
the situation as a region
as the minister highlighted
the
cooperation between
them is very important as for modalities
of this meeting minister will provide
additional information
armenian azerbaijans are still
inconsistent with the obligations
regarding
the returning of uh
military hostages how to assess the
situation we know that uh due to the
anniversary of the beginning of military
conflict in nagorno-karabakh solomon
west took place in the british nebraska
we
share
the sympathy towards the
close people to all those who perished
from both sides of the conflict we
believe that
the statements by russia armenia and
azerbaijan as of the 9th of november
2020 and the 11th of january 2021
uh are a solid guarantee of
avoiding such tragic events in the
future we continued our work to
set free all the military prisoners or
the prisoners of war and providing mine
maps
the next question
several days ago vice prime minister of
russia alexey verchook said
that no issue
of creating a corridor had been
discussed in trilateral forum despite
that president of azerbaijan continued
to distort the absence of trilateral
agreements in particular isham ali for
the president of azerbaijan said once
again that
the so-called zangazoo corridor was
supposed to be allotment i quote we
are patient and however our patient has
its limits the second war in caribbean
showed that
showed what happens when our
patients
is uh
is no more enough how do you assess
his statement we understand that mass
media
are interested in such hot news and
statements however we believe that
talking in detail about such
confrontational subjects do not
contribute to overcoming the existing
differences
it is important to ensure all the means
to find mutually acceptable decisions we
confirm
that such a dialect such as sentiment is
important
trilateral working group aimed at
de-blocking economic and transport ties
in trans caucuses continue its
activities at the level of vice prime
minister and russians urban and america
we confirm
uh the willingness of europe to achieve
mutually
uh acceptable agreements
thank you and the last question
based resolution includes the proposal
by armenia on establishing a
demilitarized zone
close to the border of armenia
and it also calls for both parties to
consider establishing a demilitarized
zone involving peacekeepers and military
monitoring forces the creation of such
zone is the only efficient way to
prevent criminal actions of the
azerbaijani
military and what's the opinion of the
russian side on this matter uh well as
far as we understand you're talking
about the resolution by the
parliamentary assembly of the council of
europe that was adopted on the 27th of
september on humanitarian repercussions
of the conflict between armenia and
azerbaijan in the course of the
discussion of this document both armenia
and azerbaijan
requested
full support for russian support
and we have repeatedly highlighted that
sustainable and long-term solution to
the problem
on a certain border of on certain areas
of armenian azerbaijani border
is the establishment of the
demolition commission
um and further demarcation of the border
and the russian side
provided its proposals and we look
forward for the feedback thank you
vesnik kavkaza i believe you had the
question yes indeed good day as a
follow-up to the
regional situation
president of azerbaijan ilham alif
previously stated that he is ready to
have a personal meeting with prime
minister of armenia nicole pacinian
under the auspices of the osce miss
group should the men's group propose to
have such a meeting
what's russian take on this statement
and do you have any details on this
meeting
are you preparing for it russia has
always assumed that the regular dialect
especially at the high-end summit levels
help
reach mutual understanding
and
creating constructive environment to
address existing grievances and thanks
to intensive contacts between president
putin and leaders of ezeberton and
armenia
we have managed to put an end to the
bloodshed in nagorno-karabakh as you
understand organization of such meetings
at the summit level requires quite a
serious preparation we assume that the
trip that we've mentioned by co-chairs
of the men's group in the region will
help establish favorable conditions
thank you
as newspaper armenia
are you with us
ragnam
information
agency are here
yes
hello
hello alexia natolivic today we have two
questions and both questions are about
kosovo
the first one
how does the russian mfa comment on the
statement of the so-called president of
separatist kosovo
suggesting that
authorities in belgrade are fueling up
tension in northern kosovo and
mitochondria under the russian influence
and they try to destabilize the whole
region how do such accusations fit with
russian position according to which the
solution on kosovo should be developed
on the basis of international law
abiding by previous arrangements between
belgrade and pristina
well as for the russian assessments
they are drastically different from this
politicized opinion of the so-called
president of kosovo over the past days
they have been outlined in the comments
that you can study at the official
website of the russian foreign ministry
and
there's no point
to repeat them
and the second question
just on the eve of the briefing we got
reports that belgrade and pristina
reached some arrangement on
car license numbers
so um how does the russian foreign
ministry see a long-term solution
to this problem
given that pristina
justifies its actions
appealing to 2016
agreement on reciprocity and it
highlights that the sovereign side
agreed to it and signed it
should be abide by this agreement
according to the russian side
well this issue has
a background the agreement between
belgrade and pristina of the 14th of
september 2016
that
also has a successor an agreement on the
freedom of movement of 2011
which are fully accessible
and it clearly stipulates that the
kosovo extends the action the
validity of the license numbers for five
years after that the parties will once
again discuss this issue clearly the
discussions um in 2016 uh stipulated
that
they should be held at the negotiation
table involving the parties to the
conflict
uh but at the same time we see a blatant
and flagrant violation of
the
commitments by kosovo albanians
given the
lack of resolution to this
matter of movement
the moscow post
good evening can you hear me
now there's the popover i have two
questions
at the end general assembly minister
lavrov
met
eu
and japanese
representatives
with joseph borel he discussed stability
and predictability in relations
as we see it uh primarily
for russia it pertains to the eu role in
resolving the crisis in donbass what can
you expect from brussels in this regard
in terms of stability and predictability
of the eu policy in ukraine indeed
prospects of russia eu relations were
discussed at the meeting of minister
lavrov with high commission of the eu
for foreign affairs
joseph burrell at new york at the eu at
the united nations general assembly
in new york
and they stated
the mutual interest in
developing in a predictable and win-win
way
where
neighbors were important trade and
economic partners
and it is not it is pointless to
put
the development of relations between
russia and its european
allies independence
from the settlement of certain regional
and domestic conflicts speech conflict
in ukraine or somewhere else
this is a nefarious logic
that is
guiding
eu
prospects for cooperation between russia
and the eu
that could significantly uh bolster the
positions of the eu continent
has been
made dependent
uh from the minsk agreements talking
about stability and predictability with
the eu
we are talking about importance of
rebuilding the priority of an equal
creative cooperation that is aimed at
implementing long-term interests of our
countries and peoples
we could hardly
return to the business as usual in the
near future
at the same time we have
interest in working with the eu and its
member states in the spirit of
pragmatism and good neighborly relations
however good neighbors
are
behaving in an inappropriate
matter they
do not
get involved into domestic affairs
and they do not launch sweeping
accusations and accuse each other of
illegal international
measures
and
the instructions that we see in eu
doctrines
deterrence
could hardly
be compatible with the prospect of
building stable and predictable
relations between russia and the eu
a such state of affairs does not meet
the interests of any of the countries
and it should be rectified
we should not
be creative here because uh there are
some universal and fundamental
principles of international law
um namely the u.n charter the principle
of sovereign equality non-interference
into domestic affairs cooperation
between states that we should be guided
by s for stability and predictability
we expect that the eu will stop turning
a blind eye to the undermining bike of
the minsk agreements and we hope that
germany and france being the end for
participants will
prompt ukrainian leadership to
implement the package of measures
endorsed by the security council
its point is to provide a special status
to donbass
and
um return the region to ukraine and
achieve a comprehensive conflict
settlement besides that we expect that
the eu will stop ignoring
uh infringement on the rights of
russian-speaking population by the kiev
authorities which is
a violation of the country's
constitution and i believe you have a
second question yes
a foreign minister of japan mr matagi
claimed that
the regime that was proposed by russia
for economic activities in southern
gorilla islands is not acceptable
will it be an impediment for interaction
with investors from other countries we
assume that
the
measures taken by the russian government
including when it comes to the sacrament
region will become an additional
incentive for
the joint economic activities with japan
in southern cavilla islands and we will
welcome involvement of
foreign investors do these activities
including from japan
thank you
um
compatriots
magazine
good day
valeria libertav
in slovakia
there was
an exhibition that
all was opened up and it brings together
vivid materials that show
of flagrant crimes of hitler germany and
its henchmen and its allies during world
war war world war ii
i thank our embassy in slovakia who's
doing uh really excellent
work and has been doing it over the past
two years they have been providing
good assistance to us so
will this um exhibitions um take place
in other countries
especially in countries that are
infected with russophobia
thank you for these kind words for our
embassies
indeed
this exhibition showcases crimes of
nazis and their henchmen against the
peaceful population of the soviet union
during world war ii and has been
implemented under the auspices of the
russian historic society in belgium
bulgaria the uk hungary greece denmark
spain italy the netherlands norway
poland portugal romania serbia slovakia
slovenia finland france germany croatia
the czech republic and sweden currently
the russian historic society is
expanding the number of european
languages
that would involve
other countries it is not a propaganda
campaign
it seeks to
get
an understanding about the tragic
history and lessons of world war ii
primarily the historic truth about the
feet of the soviet soldiers
thank you
thank you do you have any other
questions
if there are no further questions i
thank you
and goodbye
you